i'm going to talk about um something
that's going on in parallel i'd say to
cinema right now but has a chance to
inform it and invigorate it and
obviously learn a lot uh
from it um so so
this is uh
kind of the fundamental question right
so i know that you guys have seen videos
as you've gone through youtube probably
some of ours
and and and been like 10 million views
really
why
right
it's it's crap
or or some variation of that right and
and and thinking about like you know the
the way that i i kind of came up uh in
this business and also jonah peretti you
know we we had early viral hits and we
we said the same thing it's like why did
people pay attention to us
like we weren't worth that much you know
and the content that we made was also it
wasn't the kind of content that you
would expect that uh to to go big it
wasn't the kind of content that i think
culturally we'd all agreed on was the
best content
right and that's this big question is
why is the content that we all value as
being the best the most riveting the
most incredible why is that stuff not
traveling as easily in this new fabric
of the web
right and why why is it favoring this
other stuff so that's that's the
question that i'm going to be looking at
and i'm going to try to tie it in to uh
you know the the future of cinema
so for me this image is crucial in the
understanding of this problem so those
of you who don't understand or don't
know what this image is it is a face
palm right so this is a face palm okay
it's captain picard obviously face
palming and and the the the weird thing
is that this image is everywhere google
facepalm
you know tonight when you go back and
you'll see that there's
millions of variations of this image
with text under it and all this kind of
stuff and so the question is why why
would this image which you would never
hang on your wall which is not a great
piece of photography why is it
ubiquitous in web culture and i will
pause it to you
because that's what one does on a stage
like this i posit
that
this is a incredible fulfillment of the
promise of a picture is worth a thousand
words if you drop your cell phone in the
toilet
this
is what just
happened i don't care how much text you
use to explain how stupid you feel you
will not match that
right and we start to do this all the
time in fact we have become a culture
that is obsessed with the appropriation
of images
in the service of deeper complex meaning
right emojis are a perfect example of
that and we're doing it all the time
right
every time a new employee starts at our
firm i have to request more storage for
my email account because it's filled
with this stuff
right and what better way of describing
friendship than a sloth that's giving
you a flower
there is none
it's been measured same thing with
sadness come on batman and a swing in a
rainy day
so it gets to this underlying question
which is which is potentially there's
different usages
that people have for media and one is
the one
you know when we're in this room and and
we see these incredible archival
pieces one is this notion of giving
yourself over to something it is losing
oneself into something and you even say
that i lost myself in it and you've had
this experience where you're sitting in
a room like this in a dark place and you
are in the andes i mean
they set it up in the clip before henry
it really is this appropriation of self
into another space you are outside of
yourself and you're just there you're
living it and it's incredible and you
cry you do all kinds of stuff right and
then the movie's over you go outside
into this weird bright daylight and half
of you is back in the cinema and like
you know you're still like whoa what
just happened and you're shuffling and
you realize oh i came to the movie with
someone and and and then you turned to
them and you was like you know like
what'd you think of this
what do you think of the movie oh it was
pretty good
like there's a huge dissociation between
the experience that you just had which
was transformative and incredibly
personal incredibly deep and the way you
talk about it right and then there's
this other usage of media which is now a
lot more apparent because of the the
technology that's emerged because of the
way that we can measure the because the
this sort of like ubiquity of this this
networked world which has to do with
some other usage of media and that usage
is when we use media as a proxy for
communication
right we're using media to speak to one
another in in some sort of a way and
that's that's the sort of fundament of
how we start to think about it
so
in in order to so it's a bold kind of
claim right to create a whole new
category of
of media uh consumption and but but
there's a really easy way to test it and
the one thing you can do is you can
start looking you all of you in this
room probably have shared a piece of
media in your lifetime whether it's in
an email or in a text or on social
networks and generally what you do is
when you share a piece of media you you
write something to justify why you're
doing it right you don't just post the
thing and those are share statements and
we can look at them you can look at them
you can even ask yourself why do you why
do i share why do i do it
we started to see
three
categories now there's probably many
more but these are interesting starting
points one was share statements where
people said things like oh my gosh this
is totally me
or hey this is totally you right or i
never thought anyone else felt this way
but me right and we would call that
shares where you're using media to
broadcast a part of your identity and
where the media does a better job of
explaining that part of your identity
than you probably could or it gives you
permission to or the reverse where i'm
using media to recognize part of your
identity you like dachshunds this has a
dachshund in it here you like it right
hopefully this also explains by the way
why you probably get a lot of people
sharing stuff with you that you already
know
and you kind of have that thing where
you're like mom
why would you send me that
like
this is something i learned like you
know 10 years ago i'm way past that i'm
a genius now
right but it's actually she doesn't
really know that much about what i do
you know and she's sort of like saying
this is kind of in the vein of what you
do right the second category would be
something called emotional gifting and
that's just like this made me feel this
way it will make you feel this way with
some kind of reliability and you can see
how that would really rest on simplicity
like this will make you laugh it will
inspire you the third category would be
something called social information
where what you're doing is you are
reinvigorating a conversation that
already exists in your social sphere the
share statements on that is hey we were
just talking about this the other day or
i was right
right
so so so then what you do is you start
looking at these different pockets and
you just start making assumptions okay
if people want to broadcast parts of
their identity what are facets of their
identity that they might want to
broadcast there's genetic there's
genetics red hair
left-handedness all these different
things there's things like
your sexual orientation
your
culture of origin your occupation your
location all these different kinds of
things you create these maps and then
you go ahead and you make them
you make lots and lots of them we've
made about 4 000 videos in the last two
and a half years and we try lots of
different variations uh why it's hard
out there for a lefty i'm just a quick
quick show of hands how many left-handed
people are there here
okay actually it's
under-sampled and a lot of you are lying
not the ones that raised your hand i
don't i believe you it's the the passive
form of lying um
so so it that something like that
it's amazing because people have
there's there's a whole class of
people's experiences in the world that
have been underserved by traditional
media there aren't there's not tons of
shows or tons of media segments about
left-handed people but those in the room
that are left-handed will tell you it is
a transformative way to go through life
the the guard rails are on the wrong
side left-handed people don't live as
long i'm not kidding it's more dangerous
the world is more dangerous
the scissors don't work right there's
not the the coffee cups every coffee cup
the handle is pointed the wrong way they
have to do this
just the the kilowatts of extra calories
that they have to expend just converting
a right-handed world to a left-handed
world it's incredible traditionally the
the notion when you had limited amounts
of attentional slots you had a certain
number of programs that you could air on
a given night of television you had a
certain number of uh movies that you
could keep in the theater in this
wonderful history that henry laid out it
made sense to measure your
audience as that little archival clip
you know showed and then program against
buckets trying to capture as much of the
audience into that bucket as possible
and it created terms like minimum viable
relatability in the 90s in television
program and that generally
moves towards generality into
regressions of the mean right and what
it does is it leaves out a lot of
aspects of humanity and culture broadly
and it leaves out a lot of very subtle
kinds of personalities and
and ethnicities and cultures of origin
and perspectives on the world and those
people have been underserved by
traditional media what this new sort of
ushering brings in with social where you
can recognize yourself and use media to
show people who you are there's this
incredible force that starts happening
and we have big giant hits which are
called what it's like to be raised by
asian immigrant parents
right very kind of niche niche areas
that when people see themselves for the
first time when they see this experience
and you've had it when you've read
you know a wonderful novel that one line
that turns a good book into a great book
where you say wow i've never heard
somebody articulate what i've been
thinking this whole time that is one of
the most powerful aspects of modern
media is the chance for us to fall in
love with ourselves as
as a species
again
that's what that meant
so
so there's this notion of the garden
versus the stream and it really comes
back to these two views one where
you know this incredible experience of
giving yourself over to media where you
lose yourself in a way and this other
where you're surrounded by your social
context where the media also has some
tie to different people and different
meanings that already exist in your life
and you can see this battle between
these two spaces maybe it's not a battle
but these two parallel developments even
in virtual reality where you put
something over your face versus
augmented reality where it overlays into
the context that's around you and this
is shaping the way that we think about
the future of media so i'm just going to
end on a couple things which which
really
have to do with
why
i would be talking about this stuff here
which i hope you're starting to wonder
one is as henry pointed out
this notion of down market
short form roiling experimentation has
been part of the cinema tradition for a
long long time in fact this is where the
birth of cinema happened
and
when when we when we have these uh
opportunities
to create media that has all of these
different perspectives and engages a
whole new class of talent that is not
willing necessarily to sit around for
six months to see if a development deal
is going to come through they want to
make stuff they want to make lots and
lots of stuff this is an opportunity
where all of a sudden we have uh
things emerge like i have some of my
incredible uh
talent here in the room and you know
they came up with this concept of
character universes where where you can
actually just have a whole collection of
people in a set for example and they
work every day with
stuff from micro short form all the way
out to larger tent pole
series and episodes and all the while
what they're doing is they're testing
the capacity of the characters to engage
in certain kinds of relationships
they're testing in in uh and helping the
cinematographer the dps to to shoot
better in the location to start and it
all kind of moves together in this
lovely roiling crazy pyramid so just
from the standpoint of character
development and as as henry said this
notion that the future of storytelling
is going to be transmedia these
characters and character universes
whether they're scripted or unscripted
have presences of their own in lots of
different aspects of social media where
you don't have to manage it so much from
a top-down kind of command and control
structure but you can literally let
you know talented young people do what
they're excited about and make lots of
stuff and have it bubble up into the
stuff that all of you want to get lost
in eventually
and so that's what i'm going to leave
you with is that is that to some extent
this parallel stream that i think a lot
of people do point at as being some kind
of a threat to cinema i think has the
amazing opportunity to reinvigorate it
to breathe new life to breathe a whole
new crop of diverse talent diverse
viewpoints diversity experiences into
this hallowed amazing art form thank you
so much